If you have Hepatitis
C, your liver
is inflamed because
you have been
infected with the
Hepatitis C virus.
Your liver is the largest
organ inside your body
and performs many
important functions.
The functional
parts of your liver
are called hepatic lobules.
Your hepatic lobules filter
all of the blood in your body.
As your blood
passes through them,
your hepatic lobules
breakdown harmful substances,
remove bacteria and
worn out blood cells,
and form clotting factors
that control bleeding.
After a meal, your
liver makes and stores
nutrients to provide your
body with energy when needed.
Your liver also makes a
substance called bile.
Your gall bladder
stores the bile
and releases it into
your small intestine
to help digest fats
in the food you eat.
If you have Hepatitis
C, the virus
entered your body
when you were exposed
to the blood or
other body fluids
from a person infected
with the virus.
This could have happened
from sharing a drug
syringe with an infected person.
Other ways you may have been
exposed to the virus include:
having sex with someone
infected by the virus;
sharing personal hygiene items,
such as razors or toothbrushes,
used by an infected person;
direct contact with the blood
or body fluids of
an infected person;
or when a mother passes it
to her baby during birth.
During the early, or acute
phase, of a Hepatitis C
infection, the Hepatitis
C virus enters your liver
and invades your liver cells.
Once inside your
liver cells, the virus
begins to make copies of itself.
During the copying
process, changes
called mutations
occur frequently
in the virus' genetic
material, leading
to new strains of the virus.
In response to the
viral infection,
your body sends immune
cells to attack both a virus
and the liver cells
infected with the virus.
As a result, these liver cells
become inflamed and then die.
Over time, scar tissue forms
around dead and infected liver cells.
The scar tissue prevents your
liver from working properly.
If you have a chronic
Hepatitis C infection,
your liver contains a large
amount of scar tissue,
called cirrhosis, which
limits blood flow and results
in permanent shrinking and
hardening of your liver.
A vaccine contains weakend,
or inactive, viruses
that train your immune system
to recognize and attack
certain viruses.
However, frequent mutations
in the Hepatitis C virus
make it likely
that you will catch
a version of the virus not
contained in a vaccine.
As a result, there is
no effective vaccine
for the Hepatitis C virus.
If you have Hepatitis
C, your immune system
alone may destroy all
of the Hepatitis C virus
is in your body.
However, most people
infected with the virus
develop chronic
Hepatitis C, a condition
in which your
immune system is not
able to destroy all of
the viruses in your body
after six months.
If you have chronic Hepatitis
C and your immune system
can't get rid of the
virus completely,
your doctor may prescribe a
combination therapy consisting
of an anti-viral medication
called Ribavirin,
and injections of
Interferon, a medication that
strengthens your immune system.
These drugs are most
effective against Hepatitis C
when taken together.
If you have a severe case
of chronic Hepatitis C,
your doctor may recommend a
liver transplant operation.